fox news alert tonight we've obtained
leaked documents courtesy of chris ruffo
reportedly from inside google exposing
the perverse racial brainwashing going
on in one of america's largest and most
powerful tech companies one graphic
allegedly created by google's diversity
and inclusion lead claims that
expressions of quote socially acceptable
white supremacy include things like
celebrating columbus day the denial of
white privilege and the phrase make
america great again while another
graphic shows conservative commentator
ben shapiro and former president donald
trump are only a few steps away from
quote mass murders on the white
supremacy pyramid it is a disturbing
discovery made all the more terrifying
when you remember these are the people
who are responsible for nearly
everything you see online manhattan
institute senior fellow chris ruffo is
here now with more on this chris this is
really disturbing um hard to believe and
if i look at the list like half of
america then is a white supremacist and
i wonder chris is that the point that
you can crush your political ideological
enemies and still claim the moral high
ground because you know they're racist
that's right for years now that
companies in silicon valley including
google are ideological echo chambers and
this is what happened i had documents
now from about a third of the fortune
100 companies that are promoting
similarly themed anti-racism programs
and
this in the confines of silicon valley
is not only considered
not unusual it's considered virtuous
they slander and degrade half the
country and make this absurd assertion
that someone like ben shapiro who's a
person of conviction a person of
character is somehow on the road to
genocide it's absolutely ridiculous
they should retract and eliminate this
program immediately so google
controls virtually all information flow
in our country i mean it's really
frightening how much power they actually
have and so i'm not just concerned about
free speech i'm concerned about
elections i mean they have control of
information and what candidates say or
don't get to say
on these platforms
yeah i mean the fact is is that google
controls the information flow of the
united states everything from what you
search in your browser to what you see
on youtube
to all of the the image and the world's
library it's an extraordinary power
extraordinarily powerful tool that could
do a lot of good but the reality is that
the culture inside companies like google
matters and when it's hijacked by uh
biracial ideologues it can do tremendous
damage not only to google's users and
consumers but actually to american
society we have to know what's happening
in these companies inside these
monopolies and we have to make sure that
it's what's in the best interest of a
company like google aligns with the
interest of the country the united
states yes and when we see these
documents when it's exposed it should
draw serious concerns not only from the
people but from policy makers in dc yeah
but what about from all of us and i
agree with you 100 i mean our government
needs to do something about our congress
um but in addition what can we
personally do i know my husband he's
really big on saying i'm not going to
support these people that want to crush
conservatives so he doesn't use google
he makes a point of always going to duck
duck go or he uses rumble how important
is it for conservatives to make those
you know very deliberate decisions to
change where they're getting their what
platforms they're using how they're
getting their information and then
hopefully also create more uh platforms
uh and and and technology that isn't
going to
uh
you know crush conservatives
i i think it's important but i think
ultimately it will prove to be
insufficient the reality is that there
are monopoly conditions across many
different verticals
in the tech world and uh this is a
really a public policy problem when you
have monopoly conditions even if you're
a stringent libertarian it justifies
some intervention some regulation i
think a lot of these tech companies
should be regulated as common carriers
uh like you know you can't deny someone
the phone service from a t because of
their political views it should be the
same for something like google and what
we see inside these companies is that
increasingly the ideology of google
employees is actively hostile to the
united states in other documents they
say uh and other training programs they
said that the united states is a system
of white supremacy and that everyone in
this country is quote raised to be
racist
this is a deeply false and damaging kind
of thinking it should have nowhere in
america's biggest and most powerful
companies i think you're right it needs
to be handled by congress you're so
right
chris thank you for breaking that with
with us tonight appreciate it
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else